in 1996 the world's first cloned mammal
Dolly the sheep was born her birth
proved that the mammalian genome could
travel back in time placed into an egg
the DNA of a specialized or
differentiated cell gained the powers of
an undifferentiated stem cell in active
parts of the genome were reawakened and
directed the development of a whole new
animal Dolly's birth launched a race not
to clone people but to find a way to
make human embryonic stem cells from a
specific individual embryonic stem cells
can make any sort of body tissue so this
promise to provide tailor-made human
cells for research and transplantation
but making cloned embryonic stem cells
in the lab proved very difficult and on
top of that in 2005 the field was
bruised by a high-profile fraud around
this time Shinya Yamanaka finished his
own experiments he'd found a way to make
cells similar to cloned embryonic stem
cells but without using eggs or embryos
making the process much more
straightforward his technique was so
revolutionary he worried our scientist
wouldn't believe him using just four
genes Yamanaka had changed mature mouse
cells into pluripotent stem cells cells
that could then be used to make almost
any cell in the body Yamanaka named his
reprogrammed cells induced pluripotent
stem cells or iPS cells at first the
scientific community was skeptical but
once Yamanaka revealed the identity of
the four genes are the scientists
quickly reproduced his work one of these
scientists was Conrad hockey winger he
engineered his mouse cells to make green
fluorescent protein whenever a crucial
stem cell gene was active then he tried
yarmulkes reprogramming technique for
himself to his astonishment his cells
glowed green they had indeed turned
- stemcells hawk-eyed ling'er and other
scientists showed that these stem cells
were capable of turning into all kinds
of tissue in mice including heart tissue
skin and even sperm then came human
cells just a few months later more
scientists showed that our own cells
could also be rewound to a stem cell
state so much for cells in dishes the
ultimate test was to make healthy
fertile mice entirely out of IPS cells
recently IPS cells rows to this
challenge - Nature Methods has named IPS
cells
method of the Year 2009 because of their
promise as tools to study biology
although IPS cells were first made some
years ago it's only now that they are
beginning to be used in this way
studying the cellular machinery that
enables an IPS cell to turn into another
cell type could help us understand what
makes a nerve cell acquire the ability
to transmit impulses or a heart cell to
beat researchers are also excited about
using IPS cells to study human diseases
in human tissue likely to be a more
accurate way to model disease than using
mouse models one of the first studies to
use IPS cells to study disease was by
Clive Svendsen he made AI PS cells from
cells taken from a young boy with spinal
muscular atrophy and then turned the IPS
cells into neurons this enabled him to
study the differences between diseased
and healthy brain cells there is still a
few problems with this approach not all
cells that look like IPS cells have
actually been thoroughly reprogrammed so
researchers are working on better ways
to make and assess IPS cells on their
offspring and this work won't spell the
end of embryonic stem cell research
embryonic stem cells are still the best
understood pluripotent cells and it
remains to be seen if IPS cells are
entirely equivalent to them but the IPS
revolution has most definitely begun
in the last year labs all over the world
have published high-profile papers and
many research groups are starting to
make disease-specific IPS cell lines in
the next few years these new additions
to the biologists toolkit should start
to show their full potential increasing
our understanding of human diseases and
the basic workings of ourselves
you